Now let us suppose that we get a new order in which a customer wants
a chair that weighs over 200 grams, costs at most $20, and has four legs.
Given the specification, what configuration process can use this knowledge to
fill in the values of all the variables to satisfy the specification. So
the first thing the process might do is to write down all the constraints that
are given as part of the input specification. So
the mass is greater than 200 grams, the cost is less than $20, and
the count of legs is 4. Now suppose that a configuration process has an abstract
plan which first decides on the value of the cost variable before it
decides on other variables. Let us also further suppose that this plan for
deciding the cost evenly distributes the cost between the greatest
components until unless specified otherwise by the specification. In this
case the cost plan distributes this cost of $20 between the four components and
assigns less than five for each one of them. Now we define an expanding plan.
This is two aspects to it, refine and expand. Index and
aspect we deal with the components instead of the chair as a whole. And
the define aspect we deal with more detailed variables that were not there in
the chair. Consider the component legs, for example. We already know the count,
four, in the input specification. We know the cost, no more than $5
from the higher level plan. Now we can design by using the other two variables,
25 grams and wood, for example. We can do the same for the other components.
As we assign values to the variables of each of these components, we get
a complete arrangement of all these components here, with values assigned to
each of the variables. Given the specific values we assign to the variables for
each of the components, we can now compute whether the constraint given in
the input specification are satisfied. In this particular example,
both the mass and the cost of the chair satisfy the input constraints. Note that
the define and expands step in this particular process might have operated
a little differently. It is also possible that define and expand step might say,
the less, decide on the material before we decide on any of the other features.
Plus within thin complex configuration process, different designers may
use different plans and different plans to find expansion mechanisms.
Of course it is also possible that once we have a candidate solution,
the candidate solution may not necessarily satisfy the input constraints. So
the cost may turn out to be more than $20, for example.
In that case there are two options. Either we can iterate on the process,
loading the cost, or we can go about changing the specification.